do you need a new car key and remote for
your toyota camry or even lots of other
vehicles but you find the dealership way
too expensive well i'm mike with
tomahawk diy and i started tom's key
company to help you save a bunch of
money
for good luck and to save a bunch of
money smash the like button and keep
watching
now we work hard at tom's key company to
make it super easy for you
all you do place an order on our website
we'll send you tom's car key programmer
we'll also send you any new keys or
remotes that you need once you've placed
your order we'll ship it out it'll reach
your door in just a few days in the box
we'll send this extension cable you got
to plug it in
come down by your gas and brake pedal
look around until you see the white obd2
plug sometimes it can be a different
color but usually it's white take the
cable plug it in
now the first thing you need to do is
make sure you have a master key
in order to do that look around find the
blinking red light in this 2018 camry
it's right here
it can be anywhere on the dashboard
sometimes it can be up above it can even
be over
here and on a few cars all the way over
to the far left side of the steering
wheel you'll find it blinking steadily
when there's no key in the ignition
now you take your key
by the way you might want to pick up one
of these tile devices to protect your
investment and keys it links to your
smartphone so you always know where your
keys are at they don't get lost so
confirm you have a master key
as we slide this in the ignition
watch the blinking red light it's going
to turn off immediately
that means we have a master key
if when you slide in your key this red
light turns on solid red for two seconds
you have a valet key and you won't be
able to make a new a new key
unless you have a master key
so
once we've confirmed that
we're going to take tom's car key
programmer it's got key and remote
settings
we'll turn it to the key setting
it's important for you to know there's
two things you have to do to program a
key one is program the chip
to release the immobilizer which will
let the engine start otherwise it
immobilizes the vehicle
the second thing you have to do is the
remote portion
so that the remote buttons will work
and
unlock the car lock the car that kind of
thing we're going to do the key first
we're going to take our working master
key put it into the ignition
take your working master key
insert it into the ignition turn it two
clicks to the on position
the dashboard will light up but the
engine is not running
take tom's car key programmer make sure
it's on the key setting and we're going
to plug it in
we'll hear it start beeping
now you want to watch for the solid red
light to turn on
it's beeping
okay solid red light means it's ready to
program you're going to take your new
key
this is uncut notice it's uncut
take out the working key put this in in
the ignition don't push too hard but
just as hard just until it stays in
there
you'll see this start blinking now we've
got to wait 60 seconds
watch the blinking pattern it should be
a steady on off
if there's a different pattern like too
quick a pause and then three quick
it means there's a something else you'll
want to email help at tom's key you'll
know the key is programmed when this red
light stops blinking
okay it's getting close
there it stopped blinking
this key is now programmed to this
vehicle so once you get it cut it'll
start the engine you can check that it's
programmed and disconnect the programmer
by sliding it into the ignition
notice the red light went off
pull it out the red light's blinking
again
again be careful because this isn't cut
you don't want to push it too hard
just enough that it'll slip in and stay
you kind of feel it latch into place
now that we've got our new key
chip programmed we need to program the
remote buttons so they don't work right
now
here's the working one there's the one
with the tile you might want to pick one
of those up
press lock
check the alarm
unlock
it work open the door close the door
to do this procedure you want the doors
all closed with this door unlocked if
it's a hot day you can unroll the
windows we're gonna take our working key
put it in the ignition turn it two
clicks
to the on position don't start the
engine
see the dashboard light up meanwhile
take tom's car key programmer set it to
the remote setting
and plug it in
they're gonna be listening for some
beeps
we'll hear when we hear a repeated beep
it's time to open the door
there it is
open the door
now we need to hold lock and unlock for
four seconds
let go push the lock button
and you heard it beep
this key is now programmed the remote is
now programmed
i take out our working key from the
ignition
disconnect the programmer
now we've got our two keys here's the
one we just programmed
[Music]
locks
unlocks
do the alarm
and here's the original one
lock
unlock
[Music]
okay
everything works one thing i'll warn you
this after market key you might have to
hold down the button just a little
longer
than with the original one we'll work on
selling both
oem
or original equipment manufacturer with
the toyota logo and the aftermarket keys
that don't have the toyota logo there
you have it
programmed this with tom's car key
programmer if you save a bunch of money
with tom's car key programmer leave a
comment down below let everybody else
know how it goes how much you saved and
how easy it was to use don't forget to
cut the emergency keyblade to avoid the
hassle of finding a car dealership or
locksmith that will cut your key you can
order key by photo key cutting service
after placing your order simply upload
three photos when taking photos of high
security keys make sure they're flat and
you can see
the cuts
nice and clearly
you'll need the phone directly above as
you take the photos and with the wonders
of technology
we'll cut your key before shipping so it
arrives ready to fit your vehicle
one of the best things about renting
tom's car key programmer is that we
offer a 100 money back guarantee if you
run into any problems our great customer
service can be reached through help
tomsky.com and if we can't solve the
issue and get your key programmed for
you send it all back you get all your
money back so there's no risk to you
once you're all done we make it super
easy
put the cable
put the programmer back in the box
put on the prepaid mailing label ship it
back to us and we'll refund the deposit
that's charged when we rent out tom's
car key programmer we charge a fully
refundable deposit
that you get back once you ship it back
to us look forward to helping you save a
bunch of money
please leave a comment like the video
and subscribe let others know about your
experience getting a car key and remote
made through tom's key and have a great
day